In my video about my Malfegor deck, I introduced
the concept of Counterweight commanders. These are
commanders that, rather than directly
synergizing with the cards in a deck,
instead offset a weakness of a deck. That concept
as applied to that deck went roughly as follows—I
knew I wanted a deck that focused on grindy,
low-cost creatures and discard spells. Grindy,
low-cost creatures have the downside that they’re
often small and easy to block, and discard spells
have the downside that opponents can choose to
play their most valuable creatures as fast as
possible to avoid losing them to discard. By
selecting Malfegor as a commander, the deck
always has access to a tool that can allow it
to clear out opposing boards, mitigating the
downsides of the cards in the 99. The cards in
the 99 likewise nullify Malfegor’s weakness of
making me hellbent by making opponents lose cards
as well and providing ways of generating value
that stick around after my hand is gone. So here
we have a deck where the commander isn’t directly
related to what the deck does, but instead
has a mutualistic relationship with the deck,
meshing together with it to form a cohesive
whole that benefits both commander and 99. Now,
this is undoubtedly the most elegant version
of a counterweight commander among my decks,
but in retrospect I think that fact almost serves
to obscure the concept a bit. A counterweight
commander can look like that, but it can
also look like a lot of other things. So,
seeing as how this is a subject that is
fundamentally related to my deckbuilding,
and how I haven’t dedicated a video to it aside
from a little 5 minute thing in July of last year,
I’m going to give the concept a full discussion.
I’m going to discuss the conceptual roots of it,
give some additional examples, and talk
about how it fits into the broader EDH
ecosystem, as well as discuss some of the
limitations of this style of deckbuilding.
To start with, let’s return to the definition
I gave earlier. A counterweight commander is
a commander that serves to cover the weaknesses
of a given deck. It’s easy to imagine that this
is a revolutionary innovation that I came up with
and have been employing under the radar for years
before finally, now, spilling my secrets. However,
the truth is much more mundane. Fundamentally,
the idea of a counterweight commander
emerges naturally from the process of
rigorously interrogating what, in exact detail,
your command zone is offering you in a given
deck. As commander players it’s easy to slip
into a mode of existence where we forget the
rules of the format, or rather, where we calcify
a specific understanding of the commander format
in our brains. Almost all popular commanders fall
into one of two categories—they’re an enabler for
a particular thing, or more commonly they’re a
payoff for doing a thing. Decks are supposed to
have one or more themes, and then a commander
that helps out with one of those themes. A lot
of players internalize this as the way to build
commander decks, but this actually misses a lot of
the possibility space of the format. Let’s think
about the commander format as somebody who has
never heard of it before and is reading the
rules of the format. You have a 99 card deck
with only one of any given card—on the surface,
not great for purposes of consistency compared
to a 1v1 format. However, this is bolstered by an
additional card that you always have access to—an
8th card in your hand, effectively. This makes
the command zone a critically important resource
for any player looking to maintain a level of
consistency in their deck. One way to utilize
this is on the ever-popular payoff card—you
can run Isshin as your commander to enhance
the effectiveness of your on-attack triggers,
or Wilhelt to increase the efficiency of your
zombies. These are reasonable, as they allow
a deckbuilder to focus most of their effort
on those sorts of cards, knowing that
even if they’re a little subpar alone,
these cards are guaranteed to have a little
boost as long as the commander sticks around.
However, there are lots of other things a player
might want to guarantee, and other ways that
guaranteed things can mesh into a gameplan.
My high power Francisco/Malcolm deck is one
that tries to land a one drop pirate turn 1,
Francisco turn 2, and Malcolm turn 3, and then
uses Francisco’s filtering and Malcolm’s treasures
to curve into a turn 5 or6 infinite turns combo
with Time Sieve. Now, this is not an example
of a counterweight commander, and could even
be considered a conventional engine commander.
My command zone generates resources given the
input of a key card type performing a specific
action—pirates dealing combat damage to players.
However, this is undoubtedly a more intentional
command zone than your typical build of something
like Admiral Beckett Brass, even as it’s similar
on paper. Francisco guarantees that I have a two
drop available every single game, and Malcolm is a
key piece of the deck’s combo and also guarantees
a source of available mana for my 13 counterspells
even when my lands are tapped out. As I said, this
isn’t an example of a counterweight commander, but
it involves a similarly meticulous focus on what
the command zone offers a player. For a similarly
curveout-oriented example, my Radha deck has the
goal of playing Radha, Heir to Keld on turn 2
as a manadork, an Explosive Vegetation analog
on turn 3, and a stream of cascade spells and 6-7
cost bombs from turn 4 onward. By fully covering
my low-cost ramp, Radha allows me to have nothing
below four mana in the 99, thereby strengthening
the cascade cards and allowing for extremely high
topdeck quality even with a land count of 41. Now,
this actually is an example of a counterweight
commander, and a wonderfully simple one at that.
I identified that a turn 2 Radha could allow me
to eliminate the normally space-hogging element
of low-cost ramp in a big mana deck without
losing too much speed, and then the rest of
the deck was constructed to further take advantage
of that choice. If we think of a commander deck as
a stool, I basically removed one leg from that
stool, and then shoved my commander under there
as a replacement, making additions from there
with the fantastic wood savings I’d achieved.
Curve-out is almost always a factor in my
commander deckbuilding choices, but it’s
not always quite as dominant a factor as it is
in my Radha deck. For a now-somewhat-deprecated
example of a counterweight commander, let’s
talk about my Glissa deck. Glissa Sunslayer is
a 3 mana 3/3 deathtouch first strike that allows
its controller to choose between drawing a card,
destroying an enchantment, and removing three
counters from something whenever it hits a
player. When I first saw this card, I noticed two
things about it: it can offer a stream of draw,
and it’s a really good blocker. What sort of
deck can make use of a low-cost creature with
that sort of profile? A greedy battlecruiser
deck, of course. A big mana deck can benefit
from having an early utility play guaranteed,
as this makes it possible for a deck to focus
more of its space on higher-costed cards
while still having early plays. In addition,
the first strike deathtouch pairing makes Glissa
a fantastic blocker, allowing the deck to ward off
early aggression, a thing that might otherwise
cause problems for a greedy late game deck. I
eventually decided that my Radha deck scratches
the same itches as this one but more effectively,
but it’s nonetheless useful as a case study
for weakness mitigation. As another example,
my Liesa deck pairs a commander who is good at
deleting opposing life totals with a 99 made up
of lower-cost hatebears and utility creatures.
The deck’s hatebears hinder opposing gameplans
and slow down the pace of games, and Liesa is here
to be a reliable way of cutting down life totals
in that slowed environment, since she’s a great
beater that is effectively immune from command
tax. In both of these cases, the commander’s
mana value is important and they’re often played
when that much mana is available, but they can be
pushed back a bit if the deck has a better play.
Overall, this counterweight style of
commander choice is a really fun one—it
provides mechanically textured gameplay, and
it also scratches my hipster itches since it
means that my decks are almost always
different from opposing decks. However,
this isn’t a perfect method, and can indeed
lead to some problems. One problem that can
arise is that when the commander is one of very
few cards to play a particular role in a deck,
that deck’s functionality can be greatly hindered
if the commander becomes unavailable. One example
of this is a Torsten deck I built several months
back—it’s a deck that’s entirely creatures and
lands, and which uses playing and blinking Torsten
as its only draw, effectively drawing 7 cards per
Torsten entry. Upsides—packs a lot of draw into
just a handful of deck slots, allowing space
for a ton of ramp to guarantee fast rollouts.
Downsides—hoo boy, if this deck draws poorly or
gets its board wiped too early, it can sit around
twiddling its thumbs for multiple turns on end,
with all of its card draw behind an imposing
seven or nine mana barrier. When this deck works,
it really works, but the play pattern can just as
often be jarring and awkward. So this is an issue
that can come up with this sort of deckbuilding,
but for it to cause problems as it did in this
case, two things really need to be true. For
one, the deck needs to have no meaningful backup
quantity of the thing the commander is providing.
My Malfegor deck would really struggle if it
didn’t have a way to clear out opposing boards,
but it runs a decent removal suite in addition to
the commander for that exact reason, including a
handful of small creature wipes intended to hinder
token players who might otherwise get out of hand.
By contrast the Torsten deck has literally no draw
outside of the command zone due to how tight
space is in the deck, unless you count Selvala
as draw. Secondly, the thing that the commander
is providing needs to be a key requirement for
the long-term functioning of the deck in order
for there to be a problem. My Radha deck has
absolutely no low-cost ramp aside from Radha
herself, and as some people have pointed out,
the commander getting removed immediately does
cause me to basically skip my turn 3. But this
rarely happens because it’s not actually a
particularly good usage of removal—this is
an inevitability deck not a tempo deck, and a
one-turn setback for a slower deck just isn’t
that big a deal in mid-power EDH. When Radha dies
early, I shrug, garner a bit of table sympathy,
and then proceed normally starting on turn
4. By contrast, my Torsten deck requires
constant access to him, and any barrier to
utilizing him stonewalls the deck’s gameplan.
The other potential issue with counterweight
commanders is that it can lead to decks that
some might find a bit bland in terms of card
choice. As you may have noticed earlier,
I actually titled my original video on this
topic “A Weird Trick to Making Cool Midrange
Decks,” which certainly indicates something.
It is true that a lot of decks do end up moving
somewhat in this direction—my Glissa deck
is a pile of generic dudes, my Radha deck
is a cascade-flavored pile of generic dudes,
my Liesa deck is a lower-curved and somewhat
staxy pile of generic dudes, and if you squint
around the interesting bits, my Malfegor deck
is also kind of a pile of generic dudes. This
fundamentally comes down to the nature of the
strategy—at its core the counterweight commander
method is all about rejecting direct synergy with
the commander in favor of a gameplan that meshes
with the commander indirectly. In EDH broadly,
the commander of a deck will often be a central
node to begin building a deck’s synergies off of,
so without that direct synergy relationship
it’s easy to end up grabbing best-in-class
cards rather than ones that perform to a specific
dynamic or synergistic gameplan. This doesn’t mean
that all decks with this method need to lack
synergy—my Malfegor deck has a bit of direct
synergy with self-discard, and some other synergy
packages that relate to the sorts of gamestates my
Demon Dragon friend promotes, and my Radha deck
likewise features a decent amount of cascade as
a natural offshoot from having a commander that
allows me to run very few low cost cards. It’s
fully possible to make interesting, synergistic
decks within the bounds of this method, but it
is undoubtedly more difficult, and I consider
finding interesting dynamics and card choices
within the counterweight commander framework to
be just one of the fun challenges of the method.
To cap off the video, I’m going to give one
more example of a counterweight commander
deck that is something of a deviation from the
midrange framework—and actually, it was the
first one I ever built. In 2019, I built a $25
budget combo-control Orzhov deck with Kambal,
Consul of Allocation as the commander.
Unlike a lot of common control commanders,
Kambal doesn’t help generate value or control
the board; rather, he’s simply a three mana
2/3 that drains an opponent for two points of
life whenever they cast a noncreature spell. So,
what’s he here for? Well primarily, lifegain,
which Kambal guarantees a near-constant source
of. Now, lifegain isn’t a particularly useful
thing on its own. Life totals are a key factor
for winning the game, yes, but tempo and value
tend to be more important contributors to the
winning and losing of games, particularly in
a format like commander where life totals are
high by default. Nor is this a deck with
much in the way of lifegain synergies,
effects that trigger when life is gained. So
where does lifegain fit in here? Well for one,
control decks tend to be weak to life
total pressure, so this helps with that,
but lifegain also helps control decks in another
way. See, in a deck with a lot of boardwipes,
opponents will deploy creatures in tactical
numbers. If a control player is at 28 life, a
midrange player might choose to drop maybe ten or
fifteen power worth of creatures on board, knowing
that that number could threaten a control player’s
life total without requiring too much commitment.
However, if that same control player is at 44
life, suddenly the situation is trickier, and the
midrange player may be tempted into overcommitting
into a boardwipe. This principle led to a
semi-ironic phrase becoming infamous in my
playgroup—“controlling them with your life total.”
Aside from this control aspect, it was also
useful to have a lot more life than opponents
for purposes of winning, since most of the
deck’s wincons hinged on Sanguine Bond paired
with a big lifegain effect. As a final bit of
utility, Kambal disproportionately hated out
fiddly noncreature-based decks, such as the pool’s
spellslinger deck and the pool’s eggs deck. This
is key, because these sorts of decks otherwise
posed a major challenge to the deck, which focused
on creature killing and sorcery-speed board wipes.
This deck likely wouldn’t fare particularly well
outside the budget deck environment it was born
in, but it serves as a good reminder for what a
single line of text can accomplish in the right
environment—it can smooth out bad matchups,
indirectly generate value, and help to close
out a game. That’s the biggest takeaway from
all of this—the power of your commander
comes, above all else, from context,
the situation into which you’re dropping them from
the command zone. Arrange that context just right,
and you’ll find all sorts of commanders
performing way beyond your initial expectations.
Thanks for watching, and thanks to Archidekt
for supporting the channel. I spend way too much
time fiddling around with decks, and Archidekt
does a great job facilitating that through its
streamlined UI and highly-visual presentation.
A link to my decks is down in the description.
I’d also like to thank my patrons, some of
whom are on screen now. I do monthly deck
review videos where I go through and analyze a
handful of patron decks, so if you want a shot
at getting your deck reviewed by me, a link
to my patreon is in the description. Finally,
if you want more of me without paying money, I’m
on a podcast with The Trinket Mage and 3/3 Elk.
There should be an episode featuring Maldhound
coming out around the same time this video is,
and if you want to see that a link will be in the
description whenever it’s up. Alright, bye now.